well we took the scientific advice of
the joint biosecurity center
um they said these are the countries
which uh could now be moved to the
green uh list that means that you can
travel there
uh be aware there are still some things
you'll need to do you'll still need to
test when you come home for example
but it does mean that there's a little
bit of uh relief
as you mentioned in that report for the
travel industry and of course for people
who wish to get away but it won't be
quite like it was in the
2019 in the old days but we're a move in
positive direction
okay belaric's and madeira though are on
the watch list amongst others the green
watch list
i mean you more than most will know what
it's like to get somewhere and then
immediately have to
come back and and quarantine um would
you book a holiday to majorca
at the moment yes i should just explain
the the watch list the green watch list
it means they're on the green list it
means you can go
uh it's treated like a a green list but
we're just being completely open with
the data that the scientists have given
us and say
in saying there are one two concerns it
might mean that we're
we have to perhaps respond quickly on
there so we've said it's the green
watch list in order that people can see
exactly what we're seeing
about it and i do i have to say whoever
is booking
and to go anywhere this summer at all
you know travel insurance making sure
your flights are changeable
and making sure the accommodations
change but all those things are going to
be very very important this particular
year
and i think you know people need to
weigh up whether that is
going to be work for them or not yeah
because i mean we saw what happened with
portugal though didn't we and that was
on the green
liz the watch list and that's flipped in
a heartbeat so that my question again is
would you book a holiday for your family
to one of the balearic islands at the
moment given that it's on a watch list
yeah so actually they were just on the
green list and the reason we've
introduced the
using this watchlist category is to give
people a bit more visibility
uh over it if we think things might move
uh quicker
um so sadly i don't think i've got time
at the moment to
um take a holiday um but um you know if
people
are in a situation where uh from next
week
next wednesday thursday uh they wanted
to get away then this these are the
places
where you can go for the purposes of
holiday of course being aware of all the
uh caveats about the the risk of things
changing because in this virus we know
that happens
with uh quite a lot of regularity i know
you're impossibly busy and we
appreciate you taking the time to join
us but would you book a holiday to
majorca if you were less busy at the
moment
well as i say i you're asking me if i if
i was in someone else's shoes
and i'm not i i'm not uh looking to go
on holiday right this moment
um because i'm uh i'm rather busy
dealing with this and a lot of other
transport issues
um but so each individual will look at
their own situation i'm not trying to
fudge a question each
individual will look at their own
situation and if people have flexibility
then that obviously is going to be a bit
easier this year uh if people want
um you know more assurity there are
there are some although limited number
of locations which are just on the green
list
they don't have the watchlist list tag
uh
after it people will have to come to
their own decisions and i think most
people realize that after having gone
through coronavirus for
what is now uh the second full summer
angela merkel's not your uh best friend
at the moment is she she wants all uk
visitors to quarantine when they arrive
in the eu
no look i understand that uh germany
doesn't have the same level of
uh vaccinations as has happened in this
country
so they'll be particularly uh concerned
each country will have to come to their
own decision
a country like malta which has a very
high level of uh vaccination
haven't said the same thing and other
european countries will come to their
own decisions and i think i respect that
that's for the for them to do
but it is different in each country and
largely driven by
levels of vaccination that they've
managed to achieve in each country
okay those that are lucky enough to have
had two jabs um
what sort of benefits might they be
expecting a little bit further down the
road
yeah that's the other thing i flagged up
yesterday which is we've met with
the scientists and we've discussed this
and we think that later in the summer
if you've had both vaccinations then we
may well be able to treat
a location which is currently an amber
in the middle there
uh this country as if it were a green
list country from the point of view of a
double or fully vaccinated
individual so that means you'd be able
to come back take the single test which
is what you have with the green
and not have to quarantine um i we need
more information and data on this and
there are some difficult issues to
resolve as well
with regard to you know what happens for
example for children
for those who can't be vaccinated and of
course giving everybody the opportunity
to have those vaccinations
and if you're over 18 now please book
please go and have your
your your first job and get the second
one when you're called so
there are a number of things that needs
to happen first but i thought it was
right to give people an indication of
our sort of direction of travel what we
were seeing and what we think
might be possible i'll say more about
that next month
okay i mean i'm guessing that it would
be perfect to dovetail that into the
19th of july terminus day wouldn't it
well i think it's unfortunately a bit
more complicated than that for example
we've got uk um vaccination certificates
and if you download the regular nhs app
that's not the covered one that you use
to check in it's just the normal nhs app
it will already it's already capable of
displaying your vaccine certificate
it will show your vaccine status so
that's easy for people who
have uk vaccinations what do you do for
example for a country
that doesn't have any indication of
vaccination
status and i'm thinking here locations
where
uh for example the united states where i
think they probably have 50 different
systems and much of which is paper-based
in different states
so there are complications in terms of
how you would accept
other people's vaccination certification
and those are the things that we'll be
working through uh which i imagine will
take longer than the 19th of july
particularly for people traveling from
other countries here
so we'll we'll probably focus in phase
one
on uk vaccinated people who've been
double vaccinated
and what that means for their travel
into amber areas
okay so it's looking more like august
really isn't it
well i'd say i i your you're preempting
something which i just don't know the
answer to and i won't be completely
upfront
with you about that not least because
the joint committee on vaccines and
immunizations
have yet to opine on whether children
should or shouldn't have vaccinations
for example and that's one of the very
big areas is
what do you do if children are not going
to be
getting vaccinations so there's quite a
lot of um
interrelated and complicated decisions
to make on this i thought it was right
just to give people
an indication and particularly the
travel sector an indication that we are
looking at this we are working with the
scientists on this and we're thinking
about
how we can best apply it and and so just
in the interest of being
transparent about it we're we're telling
people uh what we're thinking about and
i'll come back next month and be able to
say more on it oh okay silverstone
planning a capacity crowd for the
british grand prix lewis hamilton says
he's worried about his fans that are in
the stands
why is he wrong to worry well i think i
i i just saw that story before i
came on i think that the most important
thing as with all of these
at this experimental program where we've
been seeing
numbers of crowds being able to attend
events we need to follow the science
uh and see uh what that's saying so far
as i understand it i'm so good there are
tests done before
on these programs experimental programs
there are tests on a period afterwards
to see what's happening and depending on
the the uh
environment what's happening so for
example obviously we know outdoor
events are much better than indoor
events for example from
from the point of view of not spreading
the virus so
my simple answer is let's follow the
science and let's see what that says and
then
and then uh be able to uh open events uh
as per uh the the the opportunities to
do so obviously we all want to get back
to the
uh the world we we used to live in we've
got to do so safely
okay got it um so he needs to worry not
uh 19th
of july uh george eustis when he was on
the show the other day
and i think rishi sunaka as well has
said that they're going to ditch their
mask will you be doing the same
well i should say actually the
government's carrying out a review
of what to do with what are called the
non-pharmaceutical
measures that's things like social
distancing things like wearing masks and
the like
uh so i'm gonna wait to get the outcome
of that because again it will be based
on
scientific information before i before i
uh sort of jump to
uh conclusions obviously we're all
desperate to sort of ditch the masks but
i think we want to wait for the science
first before making a decision
but there is no legal confunction to
where a mask is after the 19th of july
which is why he says he's
certainly george eustis who i
interviewed said absolutely it's gone
yeah well look as i say i the whole
point of setting up these reviews
following the scientific data is to be
able to advise people
as somebody i saw in the package you
paid just before i came on very wisely
said
let's wait and see what the technical
and scientific advice
that is let's wait to see what the
government recommends and then we'll be
able to make a decision
um there are people who say they'll feel
more comfortable
for example on on on transport if they
keep the mask on other people say it
should be removed what i want to do is
see what the science says
and make sure that we can all travel go
about our business as safely as possible
bit more cautious then uh now um i need
to ask you about the sun
story this morning about the health
secretary matt hancock uh what are the
rules
about appointing friends to a position
at the heart of government which may
give them special access well first of
all um
i think the actual issue is an entirely
personal um issue for
uh for matt hancock um in terms of uh
rules
anyone who's been appointed has to go
through an incredibly rigorous process
in
in government um so whatever the rules
are the rules will have to be followed
there are no
shortcutting uh that is anyone who's had
anything to do with the
appointment system in the civil service
knows uh they're they're
very strict uh rules in place
yeah i mean the we spoke to the
department of health this morning they
said this appointment was made in the
usual way and followed
correct procedure what exactly also some
time ago
what is it depends on the
specific role um but people have to go
through usually an
interview process which involves an
independent panel
recommendations are then made to
ministers
depending on the type of role uh you'll
get a a
something called a pointable or
non-appointable uh list and then you
make a
decision uh based on the qualifications
of the uh individual
so i don't think um i think it's a bit
of a red herring in in this case i think
it's really a personal story and it's
not so i don't intend to
comment on somebody else's personal life
i didn't ask you to
um i was just asking you about what the
rules were as far as appointing people
was concerned and i
i suppose i would ask you finally would
you be comfortable
appointing a universe a former
university friend
into your office well i would only ever
appoint somebody who's qualified
for the role um as i understand it this
individual was
more than qualified for the for the role
of advice was being provided
as i say beyond that uh i i fear you
tend to be into
commenting on personal matters and uh
you know
the health sects been working very hard
rolling out this vaccine uh program
uh and so i'll leave it there